because God doesn't tempt you at evil
but God supposedly tempted Abraham to do
evil when the one who told me God
doesn't Tempt with evil James used
Abraham offering
Isaac as a proof that Abraham was
righteous Son of God not that God
contradicts himself how does that work
yeah that's a good point that's a really
good point um would you say that the
like he might come back at me and say
Well then why did God condemn sacrifice
at all then the story of Abraham he is
condemning it if he wasn't stupid that
was my other
point oh oh he is yeah oh I see what
you're saying he is because he stopped
him you got it that's the point of the
test yeah I'm gonna break it down for
you right now okay yeah
thirdly the very testing of Abraham was
to show that God does not accept
sacrifices because he's not like the
gods of the
pagans it's meant to teach the opposite
point that God is a God who will never
allow someone to do evil and tempt
someone to do evil not that he's
tempting him to evil he was teaching him
that his character so now you want me to
impack it sure so in other words what's
ironic he thought this shows that God
does tempt people with evil when it's
the opposite point the point of Genesis
222 is to show I I am not like the gods
of the Nations who demand child
sacrifice because that's evil so I'm
going to show you the kind of God I am
and my character but it was also meant
to show Abraham are you willing to do
for me what the pagans do for their
gods you understand the point yeah what
is got you now I hope you guys are
listening this is going to be brought up
but if you guys are asleep and not
listening and I bored you let me know
because I want you hear this objection
the point of Genesis 22 is manifold
there's
many things that God is teaching Us in
this chapter many and it's pointing to
Jesus Christ
okay okay what is God teaching Abraham
uh so God is teaching Abraham um because
there's so many pagans around him who do
this that human sacrifice is wrong even
prior to the law of Moses yep but he's
also trying to show him a lot one number
one Abraham are you willing to do for me
what the pagans are willing to do for
their gods in other words the pagans
love their gods so much that they're
willing to kill their own children to
show they love the gods more than their
children are you willing to sacrifice
your
son because you love me more than your
son are you willing to go out of your
way to show me the same love that the
pagans do for their false gods and
Abraham said yes that's number one so he
demonstrated he loves The Giver of gifts
and not just the gift and he loves The
Giver of gifts more than the gift
because who gave him
Isaac God yes who gave Isaac to Abraham
God okay so what is the test will you
love me The Giver of the gifts more than
the gift that I gave you right and
Abraham passed the test
yes I love you more than Isaac and I'm
willing to kill Isaac to show you that I
love you more than him you with
me yep so that's number one number one I
want you guys listening to the themes
without this guy coughing in my ears
sorry okay no it's my fault for you
coughing it's me it's always my fault
okay number one I want you to understand
the points that God is bringing out
number one do you Abraham love me just
as much if not more
so then the pagan gods love their gods
the pagans love their gods I'm sorry if
so are you willing to do for me what
they do for their gods they're willing
to kill their children for gods and
goddesses that are demons that are
false will you will you be willing to
give up your son as a sacrifice to me
Abraham says yes that's number one he
passed the test so number two in
stopping him from killing Isaac he then
taught him you don't need to worry about
sacrificing your children because I'm
not that kind of
God you understand the point yes let's
read verse
10 all the way to
12 and Abraham stretched out his hand
and took the knife to slay his son but
the angel of Yahweh called to him from
heaven and said Abraham Abraham and he
said here I am he saido not stretch out
your hand against a boy and nothing to
him and do nothing for now I know that
you fear God since you have not withheld
your son your only son from me you
passed the
test
moreover you do not harm the lad because
now I'm going to let you know something
else about me that you're not aware I
will never be that kind of God who
demands you kill your children to
appease me because that is
horrendous so Abraham learned two
lessons didn't
he lesson number one if you're listening
you cannot love anything more than God
or as much as God you must be G willing
to give up everything for God because
you wouldn't have what you have if God
didn't give it to you everyone listening
yes yep number two I am not that kind of
God who ever demand of you to slaughter
your children to appease me because I
hate Human Sacrifice I hate the murder
the shedding of innocent blood the
murder of children I am not that kind of
God the gods who demand such sacrifices
are not Gods they're
demons so is it ironic that what he
thought was a contradiction actually
confirms that God will never tempt you
to do something
evil wow
did it make sense everyone yes yeah but
thirdly here's where you're going to see
that this also points to Jesus okay
watch here now why we're goingon to go a
little deeper here I hope you guys are
not going to sleep here this is stuff I
don't think you're going to be hearing
in church anytime soon I hope everyone's
listening now who cried out from Heaven
watch the angel of Yahweh called him
from heaven right MH notice it doesn't
say the Lord From Heaven
the angels in heaven and he's calling
out from heaven
right right right now watch
here then the angel of Yahweh 15
to8 called to Abraham a second time from
heaven now Heaven is God's Throne you
would think that God would speak from
heaven but it's the angel speaking and
he said by myself I have sworn declares
Yahweh so now the angel is telling you
what Yahweh says because you have done
this thing and not spared your son your
only son indeed I will greatly bless you
and I will greatly multiply your seed as
the stars of the heavens and has the
sand which is on the seashore and your
seed shall possess the Gate of his
enemies in your seed all the nations of
the Earth shall be blessed because you
have listened to my voice so now Abraham
I'm going to make you great and I want
to make sure that the blessing of all
the nations comes from your seed Now
watch how this is going to point to
Christ
okay but who's speaking the angel now
now watch what the angel said again but
the angel of Yahweh called to him from
Heaven Abraham Abraham he said here I am
he saido not stretch out your hand
against the boy and do nothing to him
now watch for now I know that you fear
God since you have not withheld your son
your only son from
me you guys caught it did you catch it
oh
yeah you were willing to sacrifice your
son for me meaning you love me more than
your son who me the angel of Yahweh
ohuh wow I never noticed that yeah I
didn't notice that either do you know
why because this Angel is not a creature
that's Jesus
Christ he's a messenger of the father
he's the one who appears in the Old
Testament the angel of
Yahweh you everyone got it
y you got it
right now how does this point to Christ
Yahweh and the angel of Yahweh Abraham
and his son okay now let me show you how
it points to Christ you ready for this
watch
here Genesis not only the promised lamb
watch now it happened after these things
that God tested Abraham and said to him
Abraham and he said here I am then he
said take now your son your only son
whom you love notice two descriptions of
Isaac your only son whom you love okay
let's see who Jesus is okay your only
son whom you love right righty then and
here it says by faith Hebrews 11:17
Abraham when he when he was tested
offered up Isaac and he who had received
the promises was offering up his only
son now the word only son here mono G
I'm going to show you that in the Greek
in a minute who is Jesus Mark 111 and a
voice came out of the heavens you are my
beloved Son and you I'm well
pleased like Isaac Jesus is God's
beloved Son and like Isaac Jesus is the
only son John 3:16 for God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
okay see the connection between Isaac
and Jesus yeah yeah see all right now
watch in Hebrews 11 17 what's the word
used to for Isaac being Abraham's only
son monogan yep now why is that term
relevant we'll see right here it says T
monog only begotten son that's Isaac
Hebrews 117 right I click here and look
where it appears John
3:16 he gave his only begotten son Wun
ton
monog right
and also appears here about Jesus 1 John
49 so you sing Isaac and Jesus are
monogan Isaac and Jesus are monogan
right yes only begotten and they're both
the beloved Son of their fathers right
yes right yes okay now watch now you are
to offer
him and one of the mountain of Moriah
correct go to the forth to the land of
Moriah and offer him there as a burnt
offering on one of the mountains of
which I will tell you now what day does
he arrive at the mountain verse four on
the third day third day
wow what day the third
day what day does God spare Isaac from
being killed on the third day what day
does Abraham receive his son
back
wow what day the third day what day does
God receive his son back from the dead
the third day third day Isaac is a type
of
Christ on the third day Abraham lifted
up his
eyes and saw the place from a distance
and Abraham said to his young man stay
here with the Donkey
while I and the boy go over there now
notice what he says something what he
says here that's interesting we will
worship we will return to you he's
saying the boy and I will return to
you but wait is he lying because he
knows he's going to kill the boy so was
he lying when he said we will return to
you how is he going to return with the
sun he's going to go kill him go kill
him wow so he's he yeah he is promising
him like you're going to you're going to
still have your
son so he is promising him that he will
keep his
son yes because Abraham knew God swore
Isaac would be the line from which his
descendants would be numbered and
Abraham knew the character of God he
knew God cannot lie and because he
cannot lie if I'm if he's going to have
me kill Isaac but he's already told me
Isaac is the one from whom my line will
continue then he's going to bring him
back from the
dead y let me show you that okay where
did where did Abraham get that okay
let's see W watch watch How It's Gonna
point to
Christ this tells you the faith of
Abraham why do you think he's called the
the Father the faithful because he knew
God and he trusted God and he loved God
and glorified God
right worshiped
God right and knowing his God was
perfectly holy and just righteous and
pure loving and compassionate and could
not lie he knew that since he told me
Isaac is the one and he made us wait 25
years and then gave us Isaac for me to
then kill him without having children
God's going to do a miracle and bring
him back to life because he cannot lie
to me and won't break his promise right
see he knew the character of his God
M you me there
yeah you with me now where did he get
that
promise Genesis 171 19- 21 but God said
no but Sarah your wife will bear you a
son and you shall call his name Isaac it
won't be ishma be Isaac I will establish
my Covenant with him for an Everlasting
Covenant for his seed after him as for
ishma I have heard you behold I will
bless him and will make him fruitful and
will multiply him exceedingly he shall
become the father 12 princes I'll make
him a great nation but my Covenant I'll
will establish with Isaac whom Sarah
will bear to you at this SE season next
year now notice what he says this is a
covenant for Isaac's seed after him yeah
right Isaac seed after him
y you with me there yes but when God
told Abraham when God told
Abraham to kill your son he had no
seed wow so he's he's letting him know
in advance his promises throughout this
whole
thing yeah he told him right there
before Isaac was born because Isaac
wasn't born yet right he goes Isaac SE
after him but then when God told Abraham
kill Isaac he had no seed all right so
what does that mean
God God keeps his promises so then how's
Abraham going
to have his line continued through Isaac
if Isaac's gonna be killed How's that
gonna happen and he's got no
children it
wouldn't but Abraham knew God can't lie
right so when Abraham says we will
return to
you he wasn't lying so what did he
reason see if you're getting it what did
he reason that the Lord would raise
Isaac back you got it and when he'd
raise him up what day would that be on
the third day yep so a type of Christ
the go the Son of God being raised on a
third day right yeah yep all right now
where do I where do we get this inside
from Hebrews 111719 watch here let's go
now to Hebrews 111
1719 by faith Abraham when he was tested
offered up Isaac and he had received the
promises sorry guys my throat pray for
me
was offering up his only
son to was said in Isaac your seed Shall
be Called see he knew it he considered
he reason God cannot lie to me he's
faithful he's good he's never failed me
I know him I know he's
reliable therefore he's putting me to
the test that if I kill Isaac he's gonna
raise him back from the dead to keep his
promise yes he considered that God is
able to raise people even from the dead
y see he believed in a resurrection yes
he believed that a resurrection was
going to take
place and then it says from which
figuratively speaking he also received
them back what does that mean as far as
Abraham was concerned Isaac was as good
as dead so when God spared him it's like
he spared him from Death by raising him
back to life yes but what day did he do
it on the third day which is a picture
of Christ so God was presenting him the
gospel